there is no reliable
question that begins with the word why
[Music]
assalamu alaikum i recently reviewed
something that
peter atkins said about why questions
him saying that they are really
meaningless questions let's take a look
at what he
said and let's come back and comment on
this
there is no reliable
question that begins with the word why
why questions do not lead
to reliable knowledge any
reliable why question must be
deconstructed into how questions
so science has no truck with wide
questions
so as you guys saw what peter atkins was
kind of putting forward was the
positivistic
notion which um
has been really said before that
anything
that doesn't conform or can be
investigated by
the scientific method would be rendered
meaningless by definition
and this is flawed for many reasons
one of those reasons is that this is a
self-defeating
self-refuting postulation the scientific
method itself
is not subject to the scientific
method in other words the scientific
method
is a series of steps
of how to investigate natural
phenomena those steps
which are for all intents and purposes
not
empirically justified cannot be
put under a microscope likewise
like many have said including massimo
pigliucci
that the deontology or the ontology of
ethics or the mathematics
of the philosophy of mathematics all of
those things
and more are things which the scientific
method
has no particular access to
that is not to say that morality does
not exist
or that mathematics even more absurdly
does not exist
all that predicate logic or
propositional logic or any kind of
logic analytic modal are all meaningless
things you see the reason why
positivism or verificationism as it was
known
in the 1920s and 30s
became really a redundant form
of interrogation philosophical
interrogation
is because of these questions
and more which principles of
verification
and the positivistic school of thought
or logical
positivism could not deal with thus
the idea that why questions
are meaningless is itself a meaningless
statement human beings are sentient
volitional creatures
with free will and who can
ask the question why part of the reason
that makes us
human and that distinguishes us
from the rest of the animal kingdom and
indeed
all of living matter and organisms
is the fact that we can question that we
can ask
the question why and i regularly ask
people
that in this life that we live
and in this world in which we inhabit
how and why is it the case that we were
chucked
thrown into life in the way
that we have been thrown into life
and that there is no purpose to life
such that we would be thrown right back
out i think the existence of sentience
of volition and of free will
is itself an evidence for the fact
that there is some decision to be made
because free will would otherwise be
redundant a redundant
feature of the human condition
the inquisitive and almost inbuilt
curiosity that human beings have
would be something which is purposeless
on this school of thought but the truth
of the matter is
that is not the case the truth of the
matter is
there is a reason why we are here
and the reason is that we may do
that we may do what everything else
in existence is doing and that is
simply stated submitting
to the laws of nature
and we must submit to the laws of nature
however the question
which needs to be asked
is are these laws of nature
explicable in and of themselves
or do they themselves require
an explanation the answer is
these laws these laws of nature
are put in place by the law maker
the one who knows nature and the one who
has manufactured
and contrived nature to be the way
that it is as muslims we believe
that this creator this intelligent
designer not only
put laws of nature for creation but sent
prophets and messengers are full time
to communicate the human guidance
in the form of revelation
and those prophets that you've heard
maybe growing up
in sunday school if you come from the
judo christian tradition
or madrasa if you are from the muslim
tradition
like moses and abraham and jesus
are individuals who merely communicated
that guidance to human beings
we believe as muslims that the final of
those messengers
was the prophet muhammad himself who
came with the quran and this i believe
is not only intellectually satisfying
it's not only an intellectually
satisfying proposition
but is one which can be evidenced
and rationalized but that will be for
another day
i'm going to be doing a series on the
sapiens institute channel
where in which we review all the
arguments for and against islam
as a religion and where in which we will
be
arguing for islam
by showing the proofs that islam
is the truth wasallam alaikum
warahmatullahi